these two cute koalas are a background
image inside a div and right now the
background size is set to cover I want
you to compare the difference between
background size cover and background
size contain it might help if you resize
the page a bit to figure out the
difference between the two once you
think you know the difference between
cover and contain I have two statements
for you the first one says that the
image is sized so that it is as small as
possible while still completely filling
its container is that describing contain
or cover pick one of the two and the
second statement says the image is size
that it is as large as possible while
still being completely visible inside
its container is this statement
describing contain or cover pick one of
these two